في دائره العاصمه السودانيه تتركز معارك
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع مع
اقتراب المعارك من انهاء شهرها الثاني
لا تزال اعمده الدخان تتصاعد في العاصمه
لم يغب الطيران الحربي عن السماء ولم يصمت
دوري الانفجارات وسط وغربي الخرطوم
وجنوبيه ام درمان احد اهم مراكز القتال
خلال الساعات الماضيه مجمع اليرموك
للصناعات الدفاعيه جنوبيه الخرطوم تعرض
للمصنع عام 2012 لهجوم مدمر واشارت اصابع
الاتهام الى اسرائيل حينها تقول قوات
الدعم السريع اليوم انها سيطرت على المصنع
الاستراتيجي للجيش ينشر دعم مقاطع فيديو
يقول انها لقواته في المجمع الصناعي يرد
الجيش بالتاكيد على ان المنطقه تتعرضت
لهجوم من الدعم السريع لكن الجيش تصدى لها
وكبدها خسائر قبل فرارها بحسب تعبير الجيش
بجوار مصنع اليرموك ثمه مجمع خزانات
للوقود يغذي المنطقه كلها اشتعلت فيه
النيران وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان على مدى
ساعات خلت هكذا يبدو المشهد في الخرطوم
قتال يدور الان للسيطره على مست الاسلحه
وخزانات الوقود في العاصمه
المعزوله كليا في ظل كل هذا المشهد
القاتمي من هناك يقول الجيش السوداني ان
الميليشيا وفق وصفه تعمل على توسيع دائره
الحرب حرب لا يبدو انها ستنتهي في المدى
المنظور رغم التحركات السياسيه في الاقليم
الاهم بالنسبه لملايين السودانيين ان
تنتهي الحرب قبل ان تسوء الامور اكثر مما
هي عليه الان